what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and there's been a lot of awesome news
about Deadpool 3 coming out recently if
you haven't been keeping up it looks
like Deadpool 3 is sort of going to be a
Avengers Secret Wars part 1 or a
Avengers Prelude movie basically
everything that is going to happen in
Deadpool 3 is going to go directly into
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and I know a lot of people
are truly excited for Deadpool 3 but if
you're not don't sleep on this movie
because it's going to be great obviously
we have Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
as Deadpool and Wolverine in a movie we
really don't need much more than that
but we are getting a lot more but it's
also going to be extremely important
this movie will directly set up the new
Avengers films but will also set up some
things for the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe one of those might be
the actual Wolverine that we'll get when
the new X-Men appear in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now just to clarify
there are going to be Wolverine variants
in Deadpool 3 we're not talking about
new variants that just might appear for
one or two movies maybe if they appear
in secret Wars again but we're talking
about the actual Wolverine that is going
to be in the MCU for 10 plus years the
new one who might ultimately replace
Hugh Jackman we're talking about that
Wolverine appearing in Deadpool 3. which
would mean of course that Marvel Studios
has found their Wolverine and has cast
him and the thought of this is
incredibly exciting but also kind of
makes us all feel a little bit nervous
because you're bringing Hugh Jackman
back you're bringing the Wolverine back
the Wolverine that a lot of people say
can't be replaced and was perfect except
for the hype and introducing the new one
alongside of him however it looks like
during the movie we're not going to be
really made aware that hey this
Wolverine right here this is the new one
it looks like Marvel Studios might
actually make us guess a little bit but
I do like this I like what Marvel
Studios is going for and it sounds like
we're just going to be seeing Wolverine
lore in Deadpool 3 which is great
because this is what we wanted from
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness so if you haven't heard recently
a lot of insiders have been talking
talking about Deadpool going to a lot of
different universes seeing a lot of
different Wolverine variants this is
something that we knew was pretty much
going to happen we knew Deadpool 3 was a
big multiversal film and we knew that he
was going to see a bunch of different
variants in fact Hugh Jackman himself
confirmed there were going to be other
Wolverine variants and he himself would
actually be playing some other Wolverine
variants as well but he is not going to
be playing all of them in fact it sounds
like what they're gonna do with Deadpool
exploring the Multiverse running into
these other Wolverines is actually
pretty clever it sounds like they're
gonna make a pretty good joke about it
from what we understand about certain
plot points of Deadpool 3 Deadpool is
going to essentially be exploring the
Multiverse jumping from Universe to
Universe from there hopefully we get
what we wanted from Doctor Strange too
we see a lot of different variants and
based off of what we've heard so far
that is what we are going to get
variants of Deadpool himself like seeing
kid pool Lady Deadpool and who knows
what other kind of variants will see and
of course we know that we're going to
see some X-Men variants and of course
Wolverine variants in fact you may have
heard the other day that Daniel
Radcliffe has been cast for Deadpool 3
for a secret role now a lot of people
including myself assume that this is for
a wolverine variant role because it just
makes sense and it would be very clever
for Marvel Studios to do cast a bunch of
people who have been rumored to play the
new Wolverine as variants of Wolverine
in Deadpool 3. and ultimately what we
heard is going to happen is Deadpool is
going to run into all of these Wolverine
variants and he is going to conclude in
true fourth wall breaking fashion I'm
sure that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is
the perfect Wolverine and can't be
recast this is just beautiful it's a
great joke I know everybody's going to
love to see it but especially if
Deadpool goes around looking at other
Wolverine variants and then stumbles
upon Hugh Jackman and goes yeah he is
the Wolverine there's no no way Marvel
Studios can recast him having that joke
come after seeing people like Daniel
Radcliffe playing Wolverine who has been
rumored to be in the running to play
Wolverine for a while or maybe Karen
egerton pops up as well maybe Tom Hardy
anybody really who has been rumored to
be in the running to play the new
Wolverine I think this is an incredibly
clever idea however Marvel Studios might
be planning something even more clever
and that is to actually include the new
Wolverine as one of these variants the
new MC Wolverine that could be around
for an incredibly long time but of
course I don't think that they're going
to mention that hey this is the new one
in fact Deadpool might even make a joke
stating that that could be the worst
possible choice for a replacement for
Hugh Jackman he could make that joke in
the movie to throw us off but also for
something to come back to later on when
this Wolverine actor appears yet again
as the Wolverine I think it would be
really clever and this is what I was
actually hoping for in Multiverse of
Madness I thought that John Krasinski
even though that he appeared in
Multiverse of Madness as a variant could
still play the main MCU Reed Richards
why not after all John krasinski's read
Richards was in a universe where the
doctor strange looked exactly like our
doctor strange the variants looked the
same so you could say the variant of
Reed Richards in our main universe is
John Krasinski looks exactly like him
now of course all the Insiders have said
that that is not going to happen but my
fingers are still crossed hoping that
maybe Marvel Studios pulls a fast one on
us but remember variants can look alike
but they also don't have to look alike
all the Spider-Man look different some
of the Loki's look different but all the
doctor strangers and Christine Palmer's
look alike and of course Wanda maximoff
and Insider Casey Walsh kind of hinted
that this could be a plan for Marvel
Studios to introduce the real Wolverine
when people were speaking about
Wolverine variants online Leo Riedel
stated or maybe one of them becomes the
main Wolverine after all of this chaos
in which Casey Walsh responded with this
GIF implying that this might actually be
the idea of Marvel Studios and I think
it would be extremely clever especially
if you consider that after Avengers
Secret Wars the Multiverse probably
isn't going to go back to the way it was
and this is hinted at to be even more
true based off of the things that we've
heard from Marvel studios's plans for
the Fantastic Four we've heard that not
only is the movie going to take place
back in time but also could possibly
take place in Another Universe Grace
Randolph came out and stated this and a
couple of other insiders have backed her
up as well and sacred Wars is about the
Multiverse so it would make sense to
have at least one movie show the
perspective of Another Universe or in
case of Deadpool 3 a lot of other
universes so leading up to Secret Wars
especially in Deadpool 3 we're going to
start to see a lot of incursions happen
so universes are going to be colliding
with each other and we might get some
heroes in our main universe who aren't
from our universe but what happens after
Secret Wars is there a way to Simply
reset everything and make every single
thing go back to normal or is the
universe going to be forever different
and only part of the universe the mode
Multiverse restored there could be
universes that are permanently fused
together and now moving forward after
Secret Wars they have to live with each
other in one Universe a lot of people
have theorized that this could actually
be how the X-Men come into the MCU and
would explain why we haven't seen any
X-Men at all up to this point in the MCU
in which we still really haven't seen
any X-Men we've seen a couple of mutants
or I should say people with mutant genes
but we haven't seen any actual real
official X-Men in the MCU yet and
perhaps that is because they aren't
really fully at least in our universe
but Secret Wars could bring them in our
universe and if the Multiverse isn't
truly restored after could leave them
here and this is a very clever idea
because I think it could lead to a lot
of different story lines for example The
Avengers versus the X-Men perhaps they
don't get along at first you have one
Universe where the X-Men were the heroes
and then another Universe where the
Avengers were the heroes and now all of
a sudden they have to live in the same
universe is that's a perfect opportunity
to do an Avengers versus the X-Men and
it sounds like Deadpool 3 could be the
perfect opportunity to introduce the
real new Wolverine that is going to be
in the MCU for hopefully an incredibly
long time the future really is unknown
right now but that actually makes it
pretty exciting wondering what is going
to happen after Secret Wars is there
going to be a reboot are they going to
go back to phase one and have new Heroes
so they can bring in another Iron Man
and another Captain America and Thor Etc
or will they simply not fix anything at
all and say well this is the Multiverse
now it's shattered and some of the
universes are fused together and there's
no real way to undo it so moving forward
you kind of just have to live with
whatever state your universe is in the
great thing is these options are all
really refreshing no matter how you look
at them it'll be very different in the
stories that we could have could be
awesome and we might be left with a new
Wolverine for our Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Deadpool three the only
question is will we be able to figure
out who exactly it is so when we finally
watch the movie be sure to keep an eye
out and be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest Deadpool or new Wolverine news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
down below you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month please don't
forget to like the video and of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf